why did I sell my first business so I
got a great question for my YouTube
viewers love you guys
Burn Notice who wrote in to say hey Ivan
I got a question I'm just wondering why
you sold your company you said in your
last video you were making good money
and then you decided to sell it I'm just
wondering why couldn't you've evolved it
and grew with your company Thanks so
this is a great story and a great
question and the quick background I had
a biotech software company I didn't
start it but I joined it I became an
owner and the chief operating officer
and I turned down big jobs high-paying
jobs to do it and my job was the
marketing the business development
basically making a business grow and I
turn it from making $300 a month where I
thought I was failing thought of
quitting said I was gonna quit and
turned it into a successful company with
brand-name clients international
presence and then sold it and that was
all in three years
so it's pretty fast why did I sell it
two main reasons okay the first was
market opportunity so if you look at
most markets you'll find that they
expand and they contract they go like
this they go in waves of typically 8 to
15 year cycles and you'll find that
industries that have had big companies a
few big companies they start to stagnate
those industry stagnant and then a lot
of little inventors and entrepreneurs
come along and they make it exciting
again and then slowly it expands lots of
companies and then people start
acquiring the big companies say hey we
need to acquire these guys we need to
make this part of our business and the
market starts to contract again you get
back to a few big players and then it
expands and then they're so this happens
a lot you look at any industry over the
years this is what happens and we're
starting to happen in my industry the
big companies were coming in scooping up
smaller companies some companies raised
massive venture capitals one company
that raised 800 million dollars to go
out and just start acquiring
companies so it was an exciting time and
we had to make a decision to either sell
now where we can get a great price for
our company because there's so much
interest or
have to wait another 8 to 15 years
before this cycle happens again and then
be the only independent player so all of
our competitors were getting scooped up
and we're being you know brought in to
massive corporations and we would be the
only little guy left
so that was one decision one reason the
bigger reason though because the first
one could be overcome right we if we
love the business enough to last other 8
15 years or for as long as we lived we
could have kept going we could have
overcome the obstacle being the only
small player the main reason was my
partner's that's all three of us in the
business my partners who've started the
company really wanted to get to the u.s.
they wanted to live in the u.s. it was a
personal decision they they live an
alternate lifestyle compared to most
people they believe in unschooling not
homeschooling unschooling they have you
know they were living a macrobiotic
lifestyle and diet and did a whole bunch
of different things it was cool just an
alternate way of living compared to most
people and you know here in Toronto
there aren't too many people who live
that kind of lifestyle especially back
then so they wanted to get the
California because there's more people
who are doing that stuff more people to
connect with and and learn from and
share experiences with and and you know
for their kids to grow up with and so it
was a highly personal decision and and
yeah how do you tell somebody no I don't
want you to go live your dream you can't
do that you know think about me you know
you can't do that and so the deal was
finding a company that would acquire the
business but then also bring on my two
partners on a contract and sponsor them
to stay in the United States and
specifically in California and so we
made that happen I stayed here nothing
against the US but I love Canada and I
had lots of opportunities here to stick
with and I'm grateful because it started
me on my website and got me to the
venture capital
led to the believe movement and all that
and so is it was a good path to go down
but anyway that's a story I don't think
I've ever told it before so that's why I
sold you know that's why we sold the
business and thank you for letting me
share that believe for everybody
watching like a video thumbs up below
let me know what you think leave a
comment ask the question below I'm
making video response and click on my
face to subscribe to the channel thank
you so much I'll see you soon